Ryan starts off this hour in San Antonio
hey Ryan how are you I'm a new favorite
thing better than I deserve
how are you [ __ ] that's the same sir
how can I help good deal I have a
question here for you I just found your
show about two weeks ago and to give you
a little background I was in about
$60,000 in debt after college I
graduated may 2017 and I was making some
choices I was still making child choices
I was doing what was feeling good and so
I decided to take a job out of state and
move to Texas where I could be away from
distractions and I just wanted to knock
out all the debt so I also own a small
IT business and that business is
cashflow positive I bring in about an
extra five grand a month with it now and
I work a full-time salary job now my all
of my credit card debt has been
completely paid off and I was previously
saving up for house until I found your
show and I had about 25 grand saved up
there and I've been investing and
playing in the stock market with about
10 grand
I took the 25 grand and I split it
between my see the ones in my card now
so and but I still have the 10 grand and
I'm having a hard time taking that out
and taking away my contributions to my
401k because my returns are better than
my interest rates do you think that it's
still the wrong move to be making with
that 10 grand I usually well it's been
growing progressively it's at 10 grand
now that I but the risk is a lot higher
but I'm averaging about 10 to 14 percent
a month on that and my 401k is averaging
about 9% a month right now and my
student loans have a 4 percent interest
rate I think you mean a year I don't
think your 401k is making 9
a month I'm sorry to you
yeah I'm sorry about that it's okay I
thought I knew what you meant okay so
what is your income total what are you
what are you making the coming year no
your household income where you don't
pay taxes on the coming year you got
five grand from the tech business and
you get your in you get your salary
about a hundred and thirty thousand
before tax how old are you I'm 25
all right how much dad do you have I owe
10 thousand more on my car and fifteen
thousand on zero and zero credit card
okay
so here's the question that I think
you're asking and let's see if I am as
if I'm correct when you're 35 which way
will cause you to have the most money
investing in your 401 K now and and
getting out of debt slower and
continuing your stock market game that
you're playing or stopping all of that
temporarily and knocking the debt out
freeing up the cash because you have no
payments at all using that money to
invest which one of those two ways will
cause you to be the wealthiest at 35 the
answer to the question is stopping the
investing is that logical to you I mean
it is logical so the thing is here's
what happened here let me stop you okay
I just got I just tricked you okay let
me tell you what I did I made you think
long term when I bailed you 35 years old
when you were when you're presenting
your case to me you're thinking short
term when you think long term your brain
allows you to factor in risk when you're
comparing a 10 or 12 percent rate of
return to a 5 or 10 percent interest
rate on a loan you're not taking into
consideration risk and and the slowing
down of your life and everything else
here's what happens with your life any
part of our life mine too
what you concentrate on is what you win
at no one wakes up one morning and goes
you know I've never run a mile in my
life I'm gonna run
marathon tomorrow now they get up and
they train in they train in they train
and they work a system and they work a
process and they do the nutrition and
they do the miles and they wear out
shoes and they run and they're on the
run and then they're not surprised when
they are able to complete a marathon and
check that off a bucket list when you're
dating someone that you end up getting
married to you're unbelievably focused
on that person to the exclusion of
everything else to the point your
friends are sick of you you know because
you're focused on that one person and
that's called courting in the old days
and it causes people to get married if
you do not focus on her to the exclusion
of everything else she likely will not
marry you very few people just you know
love hanging out with people that don't
focus on them so you know what you focus
on on your career you win that when you
focus on electrician your body is in
better condition when you focus on
nutrition and exercise your body's in a
lot better condition and so on and this
is true here so when you focus on
getting out of debt to the exclusion of
other things on a temporary basis you
will hit that goal faster more likely
and will then be positioned to build
wealth so all of that's a big long
drawn-out answer to say stop your 401k
shut down your stupid investment plan
with your stock you're gonna lose your
butt on that and pay off your car today
and then let's don't take money out of
the 401k but stop adding to it and by
this time next year you're gonna have an
emergency fund in place of three to six
months of expenses you'll be a hundred
percent debt-free you'll be saving
towards your house and you can restart
your 401k probably won't even take that
long you're twenty five you make a
hundred twenty five thousand dollars a
year
stop doing a bunch of crap and pay off
the debt you only got twenty five
thousand dollars in debt you got ten
thousand of it in that one stock account
so we're down to 15
I mean you ought to be debt free in 20
minutes here it feels like really focus
on it don't try to do six things at once
and do none of them well and that's why
we've had so much success Ryan helping
people build wealth because we first get
them out of debt and your most powerful
wealth building tool is your income it's
not the spread of your investments over
your debt interest rate
as I've interviewed millionaires I never
interview millionaires and they say Dave
you know the way my money was I borrowed
as much as I could at 5% and I invested
it at 12 I never hear any millionaire
say that I mean never never they say I
got out of debt I'm gonna no any debt
payments I'm maxed out my 401k
oh and that tournament paid off my house
too in 10.2 years that's the average
time a millionaire pays off their house
ten point two years and with no payments
at all ding ding we started ringing the
bell and we become debt free and we
start building wealth good question man
thanks for joining us then oh by the way
to some of you people who are on Twitter
never have we talked to a millionaire
and interviewed one that said they made
all their money because they saved on
the expense ratios on their mutual fund
the reason they get millionaires is not
because they concentrate on the expense
ratios they looked at returns and
consistent long term investing they
invested and invested and invested
invested invested they didn't forgot
reasons not to invest how do you people
have a lot of theories and do nothing
with a lot of opinions about money
you're pretty sickening this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]